leute ich mache mir jetzt auf dem weg
zum michael holt ihn ab und an fahren
wir gemeinsam in einen asiatischen
supermarkt denn michael zeigen wir heute
asiatische lebensmittel ich bin mega
gespannt los geht's um michael sitzt
jetzt auch mit mir im auto ich bin mal
gespannt was mir so zeigen dass die top
asiatischen lebensmittel also
delikatessen natürlich oder so ein
bisschen komisch ja wo ich auch im
einzel kurven zu sagen aber sonst so
auch so die klassik wie du so lieb hier
sind wir es ist so viel auswahl und man
schon was nehmen jetzt erst wirklich
überlege gerade und zwar lasst uns mal
an eine stelle an sich okay
hier sind auch bei den snacks mike hat
jetzt die erste sache gefunden
bittermann ohne zuvor ein letztes mal da
etwas spendet das ist so ein bisschen
besser aber das ist richtig lag und das
kennt man hier so nicht mehr gewohnt und
wer dann doch mal rein
michael skibbe enttäuscht das ist kein
stil gewonnen
stenke wurden ja also die italiener
machen das ja auch aber nicht ob ich
glaube also nicht dass ich ihn
getrocknet stinken
guckt euch das an das sind einfach die
rahmen nudeln und zu gehen komplett bis
dahin
das ist mein lieblingsessen auf der
ganzen welt das ist dass käse von
südostasien das ist schlimm
sie werden fermentiert also gesagt und
fermentiert von dass es so der
grundbaustein und vielen gerichten
genau 60 leute hier gibt es einfach
eiskalt gegen schicken es ist einfach
vegan ist so lag das selber fertig
besteht hier die händchen
so leute wir sind raus aus dem
supermarkt und ich habe nicht alles
gefilmt es ist noch ein bisschen helfen
kann dir ja eine riesengroße tüte mit
asiatischen lebensmittel gekauft und wir
kochen jetzt einfach gleich ein
asiatisches gerichts ich wollte
das ist so ein bisschen mehr authentisch
ist und nicht einfach nur komische
sachen probieren sondern diese komische
sachen lecker.de ich bin gespannt also
glaube ich könnte mir gut schmeckte
posten leute da sind unsere einkäufe das
ist alles was wir erfahren möchte es
auch hier und ich würde sagen wir fahren
einfach mal ne ziemlich kreis lag aber
wir müssen erstmal energie sammeln
wir müssen nämlich kochen für
verschiedene sammelt man erstmal die
ganzen sachen die man nicht kochen muss
und danach macht man nie kopf gerichtet
und am ende kommt dann müsste gekoppelt
oder wir müssten so ein bisschen hier
steht sofort drauf leicht ihr so ein
koreanisches gerichts so reichs kuchen
sowie kleine bürsten sehen die außen und
die muss man in so einer chili sauce
okay und ich glaube das ist das ne caddy
zion nach freundschaft ja ich weiß auch
nicht wieso ein bisschen komisch aber
probieren wir sehen müssen aus wie
souverän stehen ein herzliches aber frau
war ja das ist nicht so meins auch also
trotzdem ex mann
ich freue mich einfach wirklich drauf
was du das probiert das sind diesmal ein
paar getrocknete so maxian hallo in den
kommentaren die neue situation was ich
auch machen werde es ziehen es gibt ja
diesen trendigen ram don wie im film
parasite und zwar wenn man diese zwei
also einige musste man eine andere marke
bin aber ich habe nichts anderes
gefunden
aber das ist auch black bean verfahren
und ich hoffe dass ich ähnlich und
zusammenmischen davon noch fleisch
an der eex hat dass er das probieren die
waren echt teur 2.499 euro spielgeld das
schaffen trend mama
man kann ich mich gewöhnen hmm
wow das ist hammer das schmeckte so
richtig frisch fruchtig aber cremig so
ein bisschen aber nicht dass es so ein
bisschen wie yogurette ist das ganze
aber so die ba ba ba in die bresche ich
hier noch ein
dann muss ich auch in echt wir haben
nicht so alles durchprobiert warum sich
dieses karikaturisten ich gesagt ich
würde manchmal denke ich ich sehe so aus
als es mit seetang wird mach du auch und
die ist man einfach so dass ja und das
ist es auch was aber es ist ja nur das
reduziert würde
ich bin gespannt kriegt man muss hier
einfach so die sie brauchen die um an
bord immer gegen das licht dann probier
mal eingeschränkt so sehr
aber das ist lecker oder es ist lecker
aber es schmeckt so krass nachtisch das
hat dadurch war es beim sushi wie ok
jetzt ein paar sachen schon ausprobiert
wir fangen jetzt langsam mit dem kochen
an der durch ganz viele zutaten besorgt
dem gericht kommen werden die zeit auch
einfach mal ist so super viel gekommen
weil ihr heute natürlich meine wii
action sehen aber ein zwei sachen werde
ich mit filmen und guck mal hier zu
bleiben
mitten im winter millionen
sonst kommt ins gericht und ja ich mache
jetzt ein bieter melonen war dann mache
ich dir nach gebratenen reis und wer was
wie ein scherz
möchtest du möchtest du deutschland
indonesien normal indonesien scharf oder
indonesien ich sterbe
wir sind schon weil ich mag ja schon
okay dass das ist aber sehr scharfen
aussagen ist es schade ja was ist dein
größter fehler
ja das sind so sachen passiert hat man
so viel spaß unsere gewässer ja schön
ist das nicht alles auf einmal geht es
am werken und sieht schon die reymond
sieben liegend ist die leute das sind
einfach chilis oder generell chilis
ungefähr so fünf schalotten das ist die
vielleicht hierzu passt sind die
weibchen das stinkt ja das richtig dass
dir
er hatte hier hinten brüssel schon die
vorbereitung für die chili passte und
darin ist diese fermentierte stimme
passte und jetzt schon nicht meine
gesamte wohnung danach stelle des films
und führte das feld krise ja nach wie
nicht mehr ganz so war schnell da drüben
kommt noch mehr würde sagen wir springen
nach den fischen jetzt einfach gleich
zum teil wo probiert wird euch das mal
an dass hier gerade einfach verzaubert
ist sieht aus wie ein restaurant tisch
und kommt heute fünf mal hier schau mal
hier ist es möglich vom kopf was haben
wir hier genau das ist die scharfe chili
passte mit fermentierte schön passt das
ist gebratener reis mit fermentierten
passte und tote fische das ist das
normalste von einer das ist am dezernent
aber es ist interessant zu probieren so
zu sagen vielleicht fange ich fange
jetzt einfach mal damit an und probiere
als ersten twitter werden bitter aber
lecker
das ist so bitter aber ich mag es so ne
das ist so deswegen esse ich das ist
bitter und schaffen
ja das bin ingenieur wolfgang duhr
center möglich und warte warte ich habe
leute das ist ketchup man ist das ist
süße soja sauce aus tunesien das ist wir
sagen wir sind jeder deutschland das
aber ich möchte dass es so probierten
jetzt in tampa
update den malereien und probier das
momentan story oder schwer zu sagen
zuckerrübe ja alle deutschen lieben das
auf bali ist mit dieses die ganze zeit
schon ist das gefällt mir glauben und
das heißt bitte lobt das gut schmecken
könnte wenn es so ein bisschen so dass
die bitterkeit aussprechen bezahlt ohne
okay das würde ich mit armenien an der
sich andere zubereitung von dem bisschen
mit soll es kommen dass sie dem namen
lorenzo der medikamente zu schreien
passend mit dem kopf dessen fisch dann
männer haben dass ich mein geschmack der
viersitzer wird wie salzig sind bitte
diese fische sie nur der gail hermann
gebt ihr das ist nicht so sagt es das
ist nun kein australien leute überzeugen
und fisch kraken fischen lecker
das ist halt echt lecker ja das verwirrt
nicht so also der reis an sich gar
richtig lecker diese fische sind dadurch
krank salzig einfach hätte man länger
ein
das kann gut sein aber zugleich wenn man
uns manchmal probier s mal kritisch das
ist egal so wie schon häufiger selbst
von mir aber so komisch das treffen und
so schnell kann das display also könnte
es jedoch leider weiter essen die also
mein mund redet aber auch ein bisschen
nervös habe seit meinem rahmen da
michael macht einfach noch zwei weitere
gerichte wir sind hier schon so lange
dran also mikey ist ehre man des
jahrtausends besucht alle seine channel
der ist ganz oben verlegt okay bin
gespannt wie machen wir
aus dem film parasite den ich leider
nicht gesehen hab ich muss zugeben ich
habe jetzt helfen mich alle aber ich
werde gäste lieben die plätze nach unten
das ist so geil auch sonst sieht so
krank auszugehen dass ist es ist also
noch immer nicht zu zwölf fertiggerichte
lasst uns probieren den ansatz der das
probiert irgendwann nicht vor allem
fleisch hat noch viele freunde hat
braucht leute könnt euch ua ronny
merkert gar nicht mehr das ist schafft
nachdem was gerade gegessen hat sich
damit so folgen ich empfehle aber nicht
wirklich nichts - heute das ist echt das
wird da ist letztere das beste make and
pins abrams sachlichkeit das gerät
vorher rießbeck darfst du wieder eine
top 100 stunden mehr habe ich nun dass
fünf minuten also das kann ich nur
empfehlen
jetzt muss das recht werbezeit gerufen
weil wenn er sogar das essen ist das war
nur ein gültig werden ja sonst gab es
kein essen drin glaube ich zumindest
sehr freuen wenn wir wieder da sind wir
schon als video
ich glaube ist nicht auf eine fast sechs
stunden ja wir haben uns auch erstmals
ein getraut ihre budgets und so ich
würde sagen ich habe schon einiges heute
getestet und probiert lasst uns doch ein
bisher war die damp links und sowas
herzlich ein an dass man vielleicht
sitzt er also minister sorry oder so
aber das hier ist der japanese mond
cache oder ich glaube dass cheneys ich
weiß nicht woher woher das kommt ich
glaube das ist chinesisch ich selber mag
es nicht okay da was schmeckt wird was
mehr erklären
das ist so wenn du rein bei größe das
erstmal das ist übrigens amy unten er
ist unser zuschauer jetzt lieber wie vor
leckerbissen ich schneide jetzt diesen
coup aber macht kompletten der mittel
durch das ministerium
erstmalig zu probieren oder wer sie
selbst kommt dass das kann ich nicht es
kann sein dass du es magst ich mag es
nicht
es ist seltsam ein bisschen oder es ist
süß ich meine es ist so ein süßlicher
kuchen einfach also es ist ein kuchen
lässt teig das mehl reis zucker da ist
und keine ahnung das ist jetzt selber
konstruktion wiki aber aber irgendwas
vorbei ist so als würde man so wie wir
uns auch eine gurke weißt ja das ist
kannst du bist so komisch spricht im
jahr
ich weiß nicht ob ich weiß nicht aber
ich habe auf jeden fall mal konnte ich
einige sachen probiert die mir richtig
gut geschmeckt haben danke für deine
geduld danke für deine cox gilt was mir
das alles gezeigt hat hätte nicht
gedacht dass ich irgendwann reißt mit
fischköpfe nässe und das lecker findet
deshalb ja schauen beispiel vorbei danke
fürs zuschauen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder und bis dahin
tschüss